foreign
and left his former president Louisiana
Silva spent most of the time trading
accusations
you should be exercised to stop you from
lying
president job bolsonaro has lied
6498 times since he took office
accused of putting democracy at risk by
attacking the Supreme Court Justices
bolsonaro accused the Supreme electoral
court and the Press of favoring his
opponent
the whole system's against me
the president said Lula who had been
imprisoned on corruption charges should
still be behind bars and that he was
only free to run for a third
presidential term because he had friends
in the Supreme Court and they had
annulled his convictions
during the debate bolsonaro announced
that he would raise the minimum wage by
15 percent Lula said he was making
last-minute promises just to win over
voters
during these past four years you never
raised the minimum wage why
no political analyst Sergio brashish
says Lula won the debate according to
two polls
needed that badly to to win and try some
some sort of of recovery uh because Lula
has the great Advantage uh over him in
the polls and according to two posters
that have resulted that have a companion
the uh the debate uh Lula one and
bolsonaro lost the debate will unlikely
make a difference on how Brazilians will
vote on Sunday but the tension here will
probably continue until the final
results are announced
azira Rio de Janeiro